now jack first of all congratulations on
all your success you did a great job for
us over the years playing these in these
different comedy boots would call you up
sometimes at the last minute
you do these bits and there was a
pattern to all the things that you would
do for us it seemed
like over and over again you would play
kind of a dim hillbilly character on our
show i yeah well i wouldn't use those
words at all uh
i did play a lot of southern characters
yes yes but uh then uh but but magnified
and uh stretched out a little bit we
actually just looked today we didn't
have a lot of time but we just looked at
a couple of the last few appearances
you've made and strung them together to
give people some tiny idea of the work
you've been doing here on late night
let's take a look at what jack's been
doing for us
[Music]
[Music]
dark that dog doesn't beat me again
[Applause]
where are you from jack you're from
georgia whereabouts in georgia conyers
georgia how do they feel when they see
you when they see oh is he really from
there
i didn't think so you really
you really when you do that on the show
do they uh what do they think when you
do that uh it's like it's like
homecoming
[Laughter]
all right what of all the different
things that you did for us over the
years what was your favorite comedy bit
you got to do well the first one stands
out my mind because uh it was the first
but it was also just so much fun uh and
i remember you actually liked it in
particular uh
i was an overly confident new prison
inmate
and i walked onto a stage these two huge
uh prison inmates are doing weights and
i'm like
listen up guys i'm new here and i'm
taking over you know
remember that yeah you do you you're
very funny as a you're very sweet you
have a sweet persona
which uh and it always makes it fun to
introduce you in a sweet persona and
then beat the crap out of you it always
commit a goal now over the years you've
always you're you know i've spent hours
and hours and hours working with you
doing different bits you always say uh
yes sir yes or if a woman yes ma'am um
is that real because sometimes i
remember when i first met you i thought
this was a put on is that gosh no no no
that's real um when you're when you're
raised yes sir it's real
[Laughter]
say it
but no that is that's how we're all
raised down there and uh yes sir yes
ma'am it's very nice it's out of respect
a lot of people get a little ticked off
because they think it's an age thing but
it's all about respect or when you're
first meeting somebody
but i would think in manhattan you must
get here you are living in manhattan and
you must you know when you're walking
down the street going like yes ma'am yes
sir and tipping your account everybody
dude do people ever think you're doing
like
yeah
yeah you're married tyler moore when you
come here you're the george and mary
tyler moore
do you uh does that uh people ever think
you're putting them on it is confusing
to to some people but uh on the other
hand sometimes you get away with a
little bit more uh because you can
always play i'm new here y'all yes it is
big and scary
even though you've been here many many
years
okay uh
have you ever been asked as an actor to
audition for a role that's clearly
against your type like playing a thug or
a real tough character yes yes um i had
to audition one time for a public
service announcement
against drug abuse and apparently i was
a crystal meth addict and so there's
this dude with the camera going all
right so you've just
done your crystal meth go and i'm like
oh
boy
well sir i just did a lot of crystal
meth
[Laughter]
my emotions are all over the mouth
and i take it you've never smoked
crystal meth oh no sir i've never done i
do bud light but uh i don't
need drugs i've never smoked my lung
collapsed in 91 when i was 18 years old
when you're 18 your lung collapse what
caused it to collapse uh it is uh it was
a spontaneous pneumothorax
your lung just collapsed for no reason
you were just walking down the street
and it is not uncommon it happens in
tall thin males between 18 and 30. oh so
i'm surprised that
that's very nice of you
i'm in my late 60s but thank you
um now did you tell your your folks that
you were gonna be on uh television uh
tonight yes yes there was there a lot of
excitement of a yes they love conan and
o'brien
um
[Music]
no i'm sorry
we'll be honest
but uh it comes on so late it's on very
late my parents don't watch this show
yeah they're i told them they're like
well we're gonna watch 30 rock at 8
o'clock on nbc and then they're going to
take a disco nap and then they're going
to wake up at uh 12 30 to watch your
show very nice
they raised your good real good